on the barricades wearing hardhats and
gas masks the protesters hurled rocks
and bricks at riot police the officers
responded with rounds of tear gas the
clashes continued into the evening
protesters attacked the police with rods
and sticks the demonstrators chased the
officers down the street calling them
gangsters and then this what sounds like
a gunshot a local TV station said its
reporters or a uniformed police officer
fire a shot in the air we had seen a
lull in violence like this on the
streets of Hong Kong up until this
weekend this time last week protest
organizers say 1.7 million people
marched peacefully through the streets
of Hong Kong this weekend we're seeing a
very different atmosphere protestors say
they change tactics because they felt
the government was not listening before
we did we did a very peaceful protest
but the government does not respond
that's why we go to the go on the street
and maybe some police think that we
brought the road that's why the pota
fired teargas and and then just it seems
the police are also changing tactics in
response for the first time water
cannons rolled through the streets
threatening to drench the protesters the
police have arrested more than 700
people since protests began in June more
protesters are risking arrest to make
their voices heard all dwz are littell
some pills in Hong Kong where she's been
accompanying volunteer medics out
helping those injured in the protests as
others run for cover petrol bombs and
tear gas sent Kelly and Yasmina darting
to action another night on the
frontlines tending to those in need
Jasmina among those caught off guard but
she's unfazed and there by shopping
centre becomes their makeshift clinic as
protesters and passers-by shelter from
the chaos
these first aiders of volunteers Kelly's
a freelance journalist
yes Meena a kindergarten teacher just a
few weeks ago they were strangers now
they stand side by side
night after night as the chaos dies down
it's time to move on Kelly and Yasmina
lurch from one battle to another as
multiple clashes crop up across the city
their reason is simple we are Hong Kong
our messaging networks help them connect
and coordinate with other volunteers
reports come in of clashes across town
it's becoming one of the most violent
nights yet news that police have fired a
live gun shot into the air quickly
spreads to the other First Aiders are
you guys not afraid for your safety die
I've raised of gunshot yeah I'm afraid
of I get injured but we have we do have
to do that and it's not just bodily harm
their risk by working on the front lines
they also fear arrest there is a
first-date pressure a target but caught
by the police
and there are also social workers that
caught so I am afraid that if I will get
caught too tonight they remain safe in a
few hours he has mina will be back at
school her students none the wiser about
her weekend on the streets